messy drives jump in Apple TV plus and
MLS subscription another Wall Street
Journal story Lionel Messi's arrival in
North America has a profound impact on
subscriptions with over 110 000 new U.S
signups for MLS season pass on the day
of his intern in our Miami debut a leap
of the prior days 6143 so they went from
6143 people signing up to a hundred and
ten thousand people one day signing up
in one day by the way that's nearly 20 x
okay Apple TV's experienced substantial
growth and subscriptions in July making
the strongest month for new customers in
2023 driven by Messi's presence Apple
CEO Tim Cook acknowledge the positive
influence of Messi's moved to Inner
Miami under subscriber numbers Apple's
2.5 billion dollar deal wood MLS
granting exclusive streaming rights
globally has proven successful even with
a smaller subscriber base compared to
ride levels like Netflix Tom well here
you go uh Messi was a proven proven
commodity comes over to the US market
Apple TV says we're going to foreground
this we're going to make the MLS season
pass and that's gonna and by the way
tell me if you've heard this story
before Apple TV wants to drive uh
subscriptions to Apple TV so it creates
an exclusive relationship with the sport
now what do we know about sport every
year you want to watch it's not like I
got I got tired of that series it kind
of got burnt out of me you know Game of
Thrones finally burned out there's
nothing new no sport is your team every
year there's a new opportunity a new
dream a new champion and you have that
it's the same thing DirecTV did with
Sunday Ticket remember DirecTV was the
only place you could get all the NFL
games and they they owned that market
Apple's done the same thing here it's
incredibly smart and Messi was
incredibly smart in this contract to say
Hey you know this thing called upside
yeah I want a piece of that you know you
know it's crazy there's three things
that's keeping Cable in business one is
old people two is Big Pharma and three
is sports watch this old people you got
a decade or two with them if you're
lucky sports they're about to be picked
up by all these other streaming
companies that are you know picking them
up three big cable TV is one president
away for making big Pharma illegal
advertising in America from all cable TV
being done and by the way all it takes
is one bold crazy president to do what
to do something that's never been done
before no you got 200 countries
worldwide 195 to allow big Pharma to
advertise we know the two we've talked
about them plenty of times New Zealand
and U.S if America if a president in
America chooses to do so you're just
going to be another one you know only
other countries New Zealand in what
space does the world follow New
Zealand's Pace no nothing if New Zealand
wants to do it go for it so streaming is
not making it easy for these guys
especially if these Sports guys are
going there and they're getting results
has anyone had a better year oh my than
Lionel Messi I was just gonna say that
World Cup champion winner yeah has has
the opportunity uh to go to Saudi Arabia
for what 400 hundred million dollars a
year and says nah I'm gonna bet on
myself wow I'm gonna take the upside
with this Apple deal I'm gonna move to
the best city in the world Miami Florida
yeah shout out to Mayor Suarez the best
neighbor in Florida best neighborhoods
um but this is called betting yourself
and you hit the nail in the head Tom he
was a free agent he'd already proven
himself he was The Joe Rogan of football
and look at him now baby and he's
dominating the MLS right now like
they're the hottest team on the planet
now you got David Beckham there you got
LeBron there everyone's going to the
games Dave grotman everyone it's the the
greatest show on Turf
and one parting shot on the business
side Pat is sports does well because
nobody fast forwards to the ads
everybody watches live and you end up
watching the ads whereas it's a proven
fact that that only about a quarter of
Americans watch the ads if they're
watching something else they have a
great point they usually fast forward
yeah that makes especially if they're
watching later and they're binge
watching I only have one friend that
would watch reruns and he would tell
everybody don't tell me I need the score
of what happened Steve the whole thing
no no he would watch the Miami Heat
games later on when he would come home
yep he would watch it on his Pace yeah
record it not live he liked to watch the
games and no one none of his friends
could tell him what the results were so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]